hello welcome back to more overwatch
hero guides Daniel Dwight here with
Chris waters Chris Mercy Mercy Mercy Me
tell me about kedusha sness heroes never
die
he's on the Bob mercy is on the
battlefield she is healing you are
healing the tank you're healing that you
you're a healer heal great wrap it up
we're done mercy reminds me of the
doctor from Team Fortress 2 and that her
power is almost entirely based upon
making sure someone bigger than her is
always a lie absolutely you are the one
who is keeping your tank alive keeping
that Reinhardt on the point topping off
all the little offensive heroes that
come back from their flanking runs
desperate for a little boost and so you
know naturally that makes you a bit of a
target so thankfully you have a weapon
of your disposal to make them targets to
you do you've got a little pistol and
that thing can do some damage and
especially if someone's running up on
you if you get flanked by your Reaper
which is likely to happen you land a
couple headshots there you stand a
chance of winning that fight but you're
not trying to pick a fight as mercy
you're trying to stay alive stay out of
the main line of fire fortunately your
staff does I once you hook it onto a
character you can do it like around a
corner you can be a good distance away
plus she also has the guardian angel
ability which is a real big help in
terms of mobility and avoiding getting
merged so not basically means that you
sort of attach to whoever you're healing
right you can kind of float around tell
me a bit about her movement I would sort
of differs from other heroes her
movement is dependent on your allies
because it's only gonna kick in if
you're looking at one of your teammates
and then she's gonna fly to that
teammate even better if that teammate is
on an elevated position if it's Farah
flying around then you can get up there
and she's got this thing called angelic
descent which allows you to once you're
airborne slow your descent so you can
kind of be in the sky you can sort of be
floating around all of these are really
helpful in terms of mixing up your
movements and trying to stay out of the
way of widow-makers
sniper attempts or anyone else trying to
give you trouble so okay I'm a hero
right there's a bunch of other heroes
there on my team Who am I supposed to be
healing you're gonna spend most of your
time healing the person that's taking
the most damage and most the time that's
the tank you know you want it you want
to switch off the tank occasionally to
top up the heroes with smaller health
pools but usually your tanks going to be
absorbing a lot of damage you want to be
putting that health back into that tank
now keep in mind mercy also has the
ability to boost her allies damage so if
you're in a fight and the health
situation is sort of stabilized for the
time being throw a little damage boost
on one of your offensive powerhouses on
a junk rat on a soldier 76 on someone
who is doing damage at range because
that extra little boost that it gets is
really going to cause trouble for the
other team they're used to taking a few
bullets from soldier 76 and it's cool
but if it's damaged boosted then all of
a sudden it's not so cool for them I'm
guessing though by default you should be
healing kind of like lucio to speed
right like always be healing but like
this is kind of a an added boost as long
as everyone's topped up absolutely yeah
focus on the healing and you are gonna
be fulfilling your role just fine
alright let's talk about our alts
because the amount of times I have
almost won games only for mercy to
resurrect everyone I don't even want to
talk about resurrect tell me about when
should you use this whenever you get it
or wait wait and kind of have it in the
pocket I feel like this is one that you
don't pop every time you know you're not
gonna if you're if you're pushing the
payload or something and you're you're
may goes down you don't need to bring
her back immediately
if you have a couple if you have two
deaths three deaths that's when you want
to be using your resurrects because it's
so powerful and it also is one of the
slower charging alts it takes a while to
get it but it makes sense because it is
just so valuable it can totally turn the
tide of a match big resurrect is like
you said just a huge game changer
massive game changer as a character as
well which is why you kind of want to
keep yourself alive last point on this
Kris who are the people if I'm playing
as mercy that I should be staying the
hell away from I mean your usual
long-range problem makers fara
your Widowmaker they are gonna want to
mess with you and really take you out
because a smart team knows that all
right we can damage the tank all we want
but if that damage just keeps getting
healed ah that tanks just gonna keep
coming so you also need to be keeping in
mind people are gonna try to flank you
Reaper is tracer our big danger to you
so that's when you really need to keep
an ear out for footsteps Reaper has some
heavy footsteps because he's a big
threat so if you hear those coming use
your ability to fly to another teammate
somewhere else and stay out of harm's
way alright that's how you play mercy
for more tips on overwatch how to play
every one of those heroes stay tuned to
GameSpot calm
you